[Music]  I see the moon sees me to relieve the  old trees the vehicles not safe  we need to fail need to fail down here  so we don't fail up there please kneel  everyone's in agreement we'd like you to  command  [Music]  well that's wrong you think it has gone  to the moon  entire world's watching I do you  question whether the program's worth the  cost in money in amongst one of the  changes are not coming back or those  tips they don't have a father anymore  great so you're gonna sit the boys down  and you're gonna prepare them for the  fat you might not ever come home why do  you think you're coming back  we have serious problems  we've got this under control you're a  bunch of boys you don't have anything  under control  [Music]  you  you